[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
ever wonder like different choices how
we might ended up no I like that and we
can tell
[Music]
you me together we were destined to
something great
you
I move here I guess it was the weather
worthy dad on that thing and magic I
thought we was trying to get out of this
[__]
sounding more and more like that's me I
it's every day my job
March sports
we should talk about you like it's 91 we
all love Thanks
[Music]
this cannot be traced back to me
champagne anyone
just go to smash things
[Music]
it's an hour
it was great to kick today off with a
look back at just some of the seminal
moments of the last 25 years and what
better way to bridge our past in our
future than with a game that's graced
every PlayStation console grand theft
auto it's been a privilege partnering
with rockstar games for many years now
and we're thrilled to open today with
the news that that partnership will
continue with Playstation 5 it's now
just over a year since we began sharing
technical details of Playstation 5 but
today's the day that we've been looking
forward to for years when we get to show
you just some of the games that
demonstrate our belief that Playstation
5 mocks the biggest generational
transition our industry has yet seen the
content was curated for today's event
showcases have PS 5 as inspired
developers to create new experiences
that are transformative and how they
look sound and feel enough for me we're
going to have the games do our talking
you
a hero's just someone who doesn't give
up
your dad said that
he was right
now it's your turn go be a hero miles
okay
let's do this
[Music]
yoshua - on gravity to italicize
GranTurismo know a javo in a shared
activity reported a cuckoo cuckoo
instead he must concur no gran turismo
ah
osaka umeda una gran turismo no - no
kataka a plethora and home to numerous
engine i cannot the campaign mode -
sinister grin senator thomas as a heat
an ottoman aesthetic design
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
yeah you're right back it appears that
the dimensions are collapsing on one
another if we cannot get to get to right
the ship I mean we can't be that far
they have found us ratchet
[Music]
how do I steer this thing asked nicely
please
the dimensions are weakening consider
[Music]
well it is certainly not good right
get off me
ratchet we are too late
[Music]
who
hi I'm Marcus Smith creative director at
insomniac games the entire studio is so
excited to be able to share with you a
first-ever look at Ratchet and Clank
rift apart a brand new full-length
interdimensional adventure built from
the ground up for the PlayStation 5
we're doing things we've never been able
to do before like use dimensional rifts
to be able to leap from planet to planet
nearly instantly or put raytrace
reflections on Clank all of our alien
worlds are filled with density and life
previously unseen Plus ratchets all new
Arsenal is more exciting than ever
thanks to the dual sense controllers
enhanced feedback Ratchet and Clank are
near and dear to our hearts at insomniac
and we can't wait to share more with you
in the future but for now here's another
look
[Music]
Sancho
[Applause]
my heroes crackin or at least a very
large octopus
I will never get used to that reality
[Music]
you
making games used to be about these
constant trade-offs between the artistic
vision and technical limitations with PS
5 we're not gonna be burdened like that
we're gonna be able to realize our
artistic vision a lot better it's got a
ton of horsepower which is very easy to
unlock and it's a machine that's really
easy to develop on the PS 5 will present
a paradigm shift as to what players will
come to expect from gaming will let us
tell stories make world's great gameplay
that I think will truly captivate the
player and really supplies quite a few
people please take a look at this new
franchise for world war serios coming
exclusively for PlayStation 5
over and over I relive my personal
illness on this alien planet
across the attack my death
[Music]
the attack
even death is no escape
each time I awake this planet seems
somehow different is it changing this
world is becoming the heart of me
infecting my mind
[Music]
I'm never easy
I speak to you
I can feel my sanity slip away but I
cannot lose hope
my only choice is to keep fighting
to keep you looking for answers
is to break the cycle
breaks me
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Josh Greer and
this is my brother Mike
we're from amber lab a small team with a
background in film and animation and
we're very excited today to share with
you the first look at our new game it's
a story full of adventure and charm that
has themes in personal growth and
redemption
so please enjoy I know you are kind
he says the power that flows through
this land
yet you do not fully understand it
driven by the belief that you can help
these troubled spirits
[Music]
[Applause]
but you cannot hide your weakness from
me
you have no power here
[Music]
[Applause]
you ever feel like you're just waiting
for a sign
to do that thing you've always meant to
do
sometimes I feel like I'm just standing
on the edge of doing great things
[Music]
but something's holding me back maybe
it's just nerves
maybe it's the fear that I'll never be
as good as what I imagine when I'm still
just standing on the edge
[Music]
but if we've got nothing else to lose
- well John
[Music]
hi I'm Lauren laning and I'm here to
share with you a game that I've been
dying to make it's an emotionally
engaging story we're rescuing is
rewarding failure is devastatingly
hilarious and the memories should last
you a lifetime
take a look they believe trusted
followed and it led them here you may
have escaped there's a murderous blades
for the fate of your entire people is up
to you
find your full voice
[Music]
translation by Benito Juarez knocking
Larry talkin bizarro
Justine deck master imam admitted or a
token Americo me ta get a candy recorder
dismiss korekara missus Renoir Co Soviet
Oh kono sekai ha T no gain predominance
supernaturally mysterious Natori oh so
kinesin Kyoto each crystal canto de
toledo - they he automatically assign
[Music]
you see things others can't
here threats others don't
[Music]
fight when others won't
it's up to you to save Tokyo
[Music]
you
look at me now count me down so give me
two give me two class
[Music]
flame witness plank
we're next play we were in everything
make way for the king
[Music]
you
it was always gonna end like this all
your hard work
all your sacrifice only sped up the
process
[Music]
and now you find yourself alone
funny death awaits
[Music]
hacking Abra cure from IO attractive in
hitman free agent 47 is back for his
most intimate and professional contract
in his entire career this is also the
dramatic conclusion for the wall of
assassination trilogy I'm so proud to be
here to present a little glimpse of the
gameplay where agent 47 is on top of the
world in Dubai
enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everyone I'm syan we're
centered New Orleans pelicans here we go
the first ever teaser for an NBA 2k 21
y'all are not ready for this
are you trying to break you down grills
you might as well give up never think
you got a chance but I don't see how got
a real tight grip when I hold that crown
I'm the first one in and the last one
out whoever owns the place gotta track
[Music]
you
amazing hot bother rocks a very recently
discovered species entirely unique to
this island
oh this one's lively beautiful seed
patterns oh and it's tasty too
welcome to the island or box
[Music]
my invitation is open come join me on
the island or where's where I am I was
trying to carry a lamp with my weenie
hands but I dropped it and uh not a
towns on fire
Oh again
[Music]
hi everyone thank you for being with us
today for this very special event but
before we get to the end of the show I
have something very near and dear to me
[Music]
[Applause]
you
Desson is a next-gen first-person
shooter about rival assassins locked in
the time loop this is our unique vision
what hacking is all about 3-4 min mazeed
gameplay a serial player driven story
smashed together what you see some
stylish action check this out she is not
making this easy
[Music]
damn
good morning black reef another day
another death our time looks fun
[Music]
see
for everyone else on this island this
place is paradise a never-ending party
we're hunting me is the main attraction
and no matter how I try to escape they
always cut me down
but I'm one stubborn [__]
every loop I'm learning a little more
piecing together the puzzle there's
eight targets and they all gotta die
before midnight
there's just one little snag
[Music]
you thought it was going to be easy
Julianna Blake black reefs protect and a
real pain in my ass she may kill me a
million times but eventually inevitably
I will break this
[Music]
I don't like watching you die I like
killing you this difference
[Music]
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to make berries for her father
it was hard and work
but the forest greeted them with a dark
cold silent
bushes empty yet determined to find the
berries the rascal broke free of
mother's grasp and vanished into the
trees mother's worried cries they did
fast as the girl ran on over vine under
branch and into the forest II what is it
with that creepy story it's just a local
tale you're really into that stuff
quit being so paranoid
are you who sent you they're coming
[Music]
[Applause]
Chris sorry
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
freedom our freedom
you
[Music]
the old ones perished a thousand years
ago
they're great cities
turned to graves
in their place
came new life
[Music]
dangerous
I must find a way to stop it
get worse
until it destroys us all
there's nothing I wouldn't do to save
this world
no depths I won't explore
no secret I want a lock
[Music]
no barrier I will
this mission is mine
[Music]
if I falter if I fail
there won't be anyone left to stop
what's coming
[Music]
but whatever comes
we'll be ready
on behalf of the entire team at gorilla
were happy to share the first look at
horizon forbidden West we're continuing
a love story as she moved west to a far
future America to brave a beautiful but
dangerous frontier mass with mysterious
new frets get ready to explore distant
lands ravaged by massive storms and take
on new powerful machines as you return
to the majestic world of horizon stay
tuned for much more we can't wait for
you to get your hands on it
[Music]
I think there's a lot to look forward to
for the community they fans are gonna be
really pleased as a game designer and
storyteller this is incredibly exciting
we're talking a whole new generation of
ideas and experiences that we can create
for the player no matter where they are
no matter who they are new experiences
like we've never had before more iconic
interesting characters more atmospheric
immersive worlds for plants to explore
we want to WoW players respect the
unexpected and I for one can't wait I
can't wait we can't wait to share them
with you is so exciting incredibly
exciting it's really about
[Music]
[Applause]
we hope you've enjoyed the first glimpse
of our future today you've seen our most
striking console design yet and you've
seen games that can only be enjoyed with
the full range of PlayStation 5s
features and power a Playstation we
believe in generational transitions and
we put years of work into making them
happen we want you to enjoy the unique
benefits of moving from one generation
to the next thank you for joining us
we're launching later this year and we
have tons more to share welcome to
PlayStation 5
[Music]
but whatever comes
I will be ready
[Music]
[Applause]
you
like I mean it's easy to get caught up
in the hype but you know I think it was
so substantial I think the games that
they showed even like the third-party
stuff it's like okay this is how it's
going to play this is how it's actually
going to look here is real gameplay
I mean it's and it's just one thing
after the other it's like you got hit
with demon souls like we'll get into all
that stuff later but got hit with demon
souls Resident Evil 8 the next horizon
game and the PS 5 you got to see the
self death blue like yo its ya we have a
lot of time ahead of us but I just want
to say like there's a very very strong
showing
and I know Tam in particular there's a
lot that made you happy we get into that
or like my general impressions are like
I thought some of the things that I
wanted but like all the things that I
most wanted they were the things that I
was most hype about getting I am so like
hyped for what I saw that I know that
I'm interested in and it's a lot of the
things that you guys are also interested
in but as a press conference I think
that was like Lucy said one of the best
strongest that they've had in a long
time they needed its clay they knew they
needed they knew what they needed to do
and also whether intentionally or not it
felt like an amazing response to what
Microsoft has been doing Microsoft came
out real strong they showed off the
console they've been talking about it
but we had we haven't had anything from
them since Sony was on the like trailing
there with little to no information and
this is the first time they've really
given us a substantial amount of things
and it's a lot and it's games it's games
that you never knew you wanted it's
games that you wanted and this games
that you now are desperate to play and
they showed off the console the console
look and we didn't get a price but we
now know what it looks like right let's
let's kick off then with the actual look
of the console itself ooh
I am super into it like I we would we
would kind of on voice chat while they
were doing that slow reveal with all the
spheres and stuff yeah yeah what's this
free is but like man I like that it has
a shape it's like this two-tone it's got
a beautiful blue accent color it looks I
don't I don't want this to sound
hyperbolic or but like it looks so
futuristic it looks gorgeous yeah it
looks like Astro Bhat
yeah I think well the funny thing was is
that in our in our rehearsals out saying
you know if I can reveal the PS 5 I
wanted to kind of look like the ps3 with
the like the George Foreman grill type
curves so you got a little bit of that
here overall I think it the first thing
that came to mind was an alienware
pre-built PC I think because because of
the tone and kind of the blue LEDs but I
am I'm super into the design I want to
see what it looks like an all-black
though because like I think am Tam you
said it like the 2-tone kind of looks a
little toy ish but man like overall that
that that design like like Lucy you said
it does have a futuristic vibe to it and
yeah it looks really sleek and I would
love to see it in my entertainment
center yeah I mean the other thing as
well is I mean a huge thing is that you
can get a disc free version like it's
it's weird because it's like what is it
the the xbox sad s ad it's like I have
been slowly moving to all digital I have
one since I moved to America two years
ago I have one game on disc and like so
the digital edition is the way that I'm
gonna go either sure yeah yeah I mean
like I don't know if I'm ready to go all
the - I kind of like the disc option but
it's great that they have that option
now from the outset and it's not like a
mid cycle introduction is recognizing
that people change or changing the way
they play and we're now in it's in a
position where digital is viable and and
like I hope I believe Microsoft
I hope Microsoft does something similar
in that vein and like going back to the
actual way there looks I'm just really
really happy that both console
manufacturers platform holders are
thinking about cons
in a different way from an aesthetic
design like Microsoft's a blessed outing
is really cool really smartly evoking
the PC architecture and you know drawing
upon the kind of like the assumption and
the knowledge and the feeling that
people have that like you know PC is the
most powerful way to play games so
they're leaning on that and then you
know we have Sony with this really slick
futuristic design that it's futuristic
but doesn't look awkward like it's
really really hard to strike that
balance and you can see just Google like
gaming laptops and you can see how easy
is to get that wrong like to do a
futuristic style piece of hardware that
also you look at and you're like that
looks disgusting and it's gross like the
accents on there the way like it's the
rounded edges like rounded edges don't
always look well they can look like you
know toys like Michael said earlier but
I feel like they've struck the right
balance between the kind of futuristic
style the accent on the blue it like
it's giving off like it looks like you
know a cool room that has like a hue
light in the background it looks like
you can see it you can see like in in
someone stream instead of being off that
off-center you know it's the kind of
thing where when you showcase it when
you're playing games you also kind of
want to have it out and looking cool and
like really minimalist style like I'm
not seeing too many ports I love the way
that they're kind of the white along the
edges kind of hides the Venning on the
black so you can't really see that
element of it you can't really see the
ports it's gonna I think it's gonna look
really cool in an entertainment center
and it it's it's the first time where
like it looks like the concept art you
would see before anyone's actually you
know a fan has done a cool mock-up of
the PlayStation 5 and it actually looks
like one of those and yeah I'm really
really like up for it and if they do
have like a pure black one that's gonna
look amazing as well you know it will
would like the blue blue lighting on it
it's gonna yep alright should we talk
about games now there's a lot to get
through
and honestly I know that I was saying
that Red Dead would be the one that I
thought rooks always gonna come out with
GT fight I mean honestly like course
it's it's it should be no surprise GTA
online is such
a juggernaut even now that game came out
2013 originally that's mm-hmm I mean
when we're now you know we're almost
arrested evil for levels of as many
platforms as GTA fibers but I'm very
interested in what they were saying with
what was it's like an expanded version
of I wonder what that means I wonder if
the long rumored and long hopes for a
single-player campaign edition will come
probably not but I imagine it'll just be
more upscaling more things to do an
online expanded and enhanced coming 2021
for PS 5 yeah I think I think like okay
I was gonna say the the it it doesn't
make it's not it's not a surprise that
this is the game that they chose it's
the best-selling one of the best-selling
games of this generation if not all time
and if you want it yeah if you want a
game to show off no loading and how
impressive that can be it's gotta be
this right like within the city and then
zoo zooming out and then zooming back in
between like Franklin and and all the
other characters like that has got to be
like them one of the most impressive
showcases of how because we're used to
seeing the only thing we've seen for a
frame of reference right now is the
spider-man stuff right like swing but
that's like apologies if I'm like miss
characterizing the way it's actually
works but like streaming in so fast that
you can't really see the scenes but like
this is a different kind of approach to
it where you're like pulling out and
pulling back in like if they can do that
in an instant imagine how impressive
that's going to look and then obviously
you have GTA online attached to it a
game that is hugely successful massively
lucrative for rockstar in terms of
expanded content like Lucy I think is
probably on the mark with some sort of
single player DLC but you know people
have been talking about more heists for
ages that's one of the things that
everyone wants more online heists and so
this could be the perfect opportunity to
have that in there as well imagine
they've been just working on this
massive collection of heists all this
time while people have been moaning
about wanting heists and now they just
put it
like there's ten new heissen this or
whatever it may be that's just like
breathing new life into one of the best
games of the generation and showing off
how impressive the PlayStation console
can be so it's gonna be online is gonna
be free for ps5 owners and if you're
playing GTA online right now you'll get
1 million dollars in GTA online cash
every month until the ps5 launches which
is crazy and I mean like if there's
anything that is gonna get you to get
back online and kind of level up and
ready for GTA 5 on PS 5 it's probably
that next announcement
Jesus this is I think this was one of
many times during this revealed that we
all kind of lost it a little bit
spider-man Miles Morales holiday 2020 I
didn't expect it this soon you yeah it's
why yeah Michael would you think of this
reveal oh man
spider-man obviously 2018 was a great
game it was probably the the spider-man
game that everyone always wanted but
Miles Morales at the front and center is
what some of our old many of us would
want as well this is it's it's man I Tam
you were talking about how maybe this is
more of an expansion based on the 2018
spider-man or if this is a separate game
we're not exactly sure at this point
there might be stories out there right
now but we haven't been able to kind of
keep up with that but putting Miles
Morales front and center is that's the
right call 100% I want it I want to be
Miles Morales I want to experience his
his experience as spider-man and yeah
this is I'm excited for this like I've
been like pre I respect spider-man like
the whole the whole universe and
especially 2018 being such a such a good
open-world game and a good
representation of spider-man but this
like I think they can do some really
bold things with the story I hope he's
not a cop 100% cuz you know spider-man
2018 you knows Loki cop vibes and I'm
not about that but I do want to see how
they handle Miles Morales as a character
and I mean if we think about
spider-verse the movie that was an
incredible representation and not just
Miles Morales but the history of
spider-man in that one movie and if this
game could do something like that come
close to that
homerun guaranteed yeah I think I think
this is gonna be really interesting it
kind of is both a surprise and not a
surprise that they moved on two miles
like he was in the original game
obviously and you know was part of
Peters story but given how successful
that is like it would that game was it
would feel like a safe move for them to
stick with Peter and carry on doing more
with Peter but the fact that they're
doing miles is such a smart and really
cool thing I expect Peter will be in
this game taking like the mentor role
and his story could be like that the
storytelling potential is in that is so
cool because the first game like this
first vitamine game is also in is in a
large part about Peter comical terms
were being portrayed by a mentor right
and he knows how that feels
and he knows how to or he's learning
himself now what it means to be a mentor
and the impact firsthand it can have or
when you are not doing that correctly so
I imagine him being in this game as as
Miles his mentor and having to contend
with you know what he experienced in the
previous game to try and be a good
father figure for miles and be a good
guide as spider-man for him I think like
that's there's a lot of storytelling
potential there and it kind of dips into
some of what into the spider-verse did
with Peter and Myles and also provides
enough like runway for them to do
something unique and of their own so
that could be really exciting yeah and
then next up we had Gran Turismo 7i I'm
gonna put my put it out there I'm not a
big racing game person either view
Michael hey like I keep telling everyone
I used to be an amateur racer I used to
be a tuner very much into cars and Gran
Turismo
okay so Gran Turismo on ps1 the very
first game is a huge reason why I was
like seven or eight years old and I knew
all about cars because of that game and
I actually took that
into practice in real life so shouts out
to gran turismo so gran turismo 7 though
from what I'm seeing like I love my sim
racing games and I'm watching this and
you know it's Gran Turismo it's
simracing in the next generation so I
wouldn't say it's surprising or I to say
it's not impressive I think it would be
the wrong sentiment but I mean the the
impressive part will come from how they
integrate a lot of the systems and the
game modes that we've seen in Gran
Turismo because there has only been one
Gran Turismo game in the ps4 generation
it was GT sport which focused on online
racing specifically there was no
single-player stuff really and it
focused on competitive aspect of racing
for racing but grants Burroughs was 7 it
obviously looks incredible like racing
games and racing games are easy showcase
to show off the power of a new console
as we see with Forza games on the Xbox
side so of course GT 7 will do that as
well
but I just wanna I want to race in the
best possible fidelity so that's why I'm
excited for GT 7 and I hope they
incorporate a lot of the the
single-player stuff that we've seen in
series past while also taking the best
aspects of GT sport that we saw a couple
years back so you get the best the
single-player you get the best of the
multiplayer and I want lots of cars man
I need my I need my skyline I need to
check out my skyline so you know what
I'm saying yeah Gran Turismo as a
franchise has always been I don't think
I don't think like it's it's it's placed
within the PlayStation Pantheon or
franchises seem so diminished not
because it's changed in any way but like
place they should have so many more
franchises now that hit bigger but for a
lot of people Gran Turismo in the same
way that FIFA matte in Need for Speed
does transcends the gaming audience and
and that they're they know Gran Turismo
as a PlayStation franchise and it's the
kind of thing where oh this is the game
I'm gonna buy this is gonna be my racing
game I'm gonna dedicate two I know
plenty of people in the same way that
you know people always say about FIFA
Madden and all these other sports games
they buy a Playstation for Gran Turismo
and they get to immediately see how
amazing it looks and see that kind of
stuff that's kind of polyphony digital
is kind of not trick but like it's it's
there it's what so many banks on them
for like you make we're gonna give you
hardware you make the best looking game
you can and when they do it always looks
incredible I mean I'm not the kind of
person who plays a lot of racing games I
have been known to live my life a
quarter mile at a time now and then but
you know I I will still buy that game
for like you know the visual splendor of
it just to look at something I feel like
yo this is this is what it looks like
now imagine the way it looks like the
game is like how are they gonna look
years from now but yeah exciting yep and
we saw Ratchet and Clank rift apart or
was it saying raytrace reflections built
from the ground from the ground up for
PlayStation 5 jewel sense controllers
enhanced feedback I'm very excited I
mean I like it just looks really good
like look at all those like yeah cool
effect and it just it's it's like you
know when um Pokemon let's go Pikachu
and Eevee and you play those and it was
like this is what I thought Pokemon
looked like as a kid this is similar
form is good yeah I think the the big
thing for me what stood out in the
Ratchet and Clank demand demonstration
the gameplay was the low times this is
an example of ps5 really cutting down on
low times you because so the Ratchet and
Clank ripped apart and it looks like
that ratchet has a mechanic in which he
can teleport between rifts and go to
different worlds at and in a split
second and I thought it's really clever
that this would be the showcase for what
low times can be without explicitly
saying it because to go from one
rendered area to another it does that's
a lot of assets to load a lot of
we know all nolo times and games going
from one area to another it's gonna take
some time even on current generation
consoles and we've cut down on that with
nvme SSDs on PC but of course as one
mark Cerny has talked to at length is
cutting down on load times and really
showcasing how strong that SSD is and
how much of a game changer it is because
because in this case with Ratchet and
Clank it's not just load screens that
are cut out it's an actual gameplay
mechanic that is being being put into
the game that shows off that that kind
of power so it's not just cutting down a
load times yeah all right we have so
many more games to go through let's
start rattling through some of them next
up project Athea from Square Enix so
this is a new one Gary Whitta right to a
rogue one a Star Wars story is a on this
project has got a bunch of other CID
like TV and movie writers I'm super into
this this trailer for me looked really
cool like I just want to know more about
it I mean obviously it's a rendered CG
trailer but who is this I mean is this
character apphia what is she gonna do
what is that - it looks like something
that you would get from maybe platinum I
think that's what we were talking about
when it was first revealed Tom what do
you reckon it yeah I think it's it's
weird because like Square Enix of I'm
trying to think of this before I put my
foot in my mouth is there any sort of
like the traditional platinum style
action game that Square Enix has in
their stable and nothing immediately
comes to mind we know them for RPGs and
and the closest they get is something
like this video so it doesn't it's not
super surprising that they have they
want this kind of game near is probably
the other one year but like project out
here it looks really cool I love the way
it moved like you've talked about the
dashing and like the super fast kind of
like timing based combat and movement
stuff is something that we're really
really into I'm really really into yeah
Gary we're writing it is interesting
like he's he's done a lot of amazing
work and obviously now known for his
and I'm a crossing talk show but before
that Star Wars and recently worked with
a very he'll a friend of the show Greg
Miller on a DC thing so a lot of writing
chops behind it
I'm interest to see more of it it kind
of reminded me of the demo that epic
shoulder for Unreal Engine 5 recently it
looked like I was like oh is this that
game but like it's it's got similar
vibes to it and so if you were sad that
you'd be unreal engine tech demo wasn't
being turned into a game maybe this is
it I think this is one of the games run
like I'm excited to see what this is I
want to see more of this another one of
those for me is stray so Michael can we
please have a cat correspondent sushi
weigh in on stray in from Annapurna
cyberpunk worlds looks like you play to
dance yeah I mean we have we have a
slack dedicated to cats in there so I
think we can all say team here is like
very big interests so the idea of like
just an interesting angle right on in
exploration and kind of like having an
adventure game this is something that
game seems to be doing way more these
days like anthropomorphic or like
straight up animal adventures and I kind
of love the idea of doing this like you
make more cat games and make more dog
games let me play as bird or whatever it
may be but like I you know everyone has
the everyone has that question now and
then when they see care and you're like
what are you doing when I'm not looking
at you and this is it going on an
adventure
oh I know what's in that backpack no
comment she says she she's under NDA so
it says well yes well that we had to do
Wow next up a new project from a house
mark people who came up with resogun for
the ps4 launch looks cool suffers from
bad
return on maternal very very revengeance
vibes from that name but the gameplay
looks cool I I think in the notes that I
wrote reminded me a bit of alien meets
prey especially with the memory
manipulation stuff but when it gets to
seeing some gameplay with a gun play
very big resogun you know bright
powerful colors lasers quickly firing at
things looks really cool I just I named
man yeah I mean it's a house mark is
very much into the like the top-down
shooters that was like just kind of
their their their Forte if you will but
this is more of a third-person
over-the-shoulder type shooter so you
know it's still channeling some of the
same energy that house mark is known for
but you know doing something a little
bit different and I mean I can't
remember if was it house mark that did
resogun on the ps4 yeah so that no
resogun was the ps4 was a ps4 launch
title so you know they're coming out
with the PS 5 launch title so that's
nice to see relationship with Sony yeah
they've I mean they've stuck to like
arcade style shoes for a really long
time and they've always made amazing
games so seeing them branch out and try
new things is only a good thing for
everyone we also saw SEC boy a big
adventure so definitely the
LittleBigPlanet license is pretty much
definitely in the care of sumo digital
now Media Molecule obviously working
very hard on dreams looks really cute
I've kind of I kind of miss suck or miss
LittleBigPlanet I just don't think
there's a series quite as wholesome will
it you know is it a day one purchase for
me maybe not but it's still very very
cute looking um big tear away vibes
there too actually
yeah I think like having sack boy back
in the mix is it's just it's just a
feel-good moment for a lot of
PlayStation fans right like that's
what's on you want to do here give us
people as much reason to pick up a
Playstation and some a big part of that
reason
could be nostalgia like even if you
fallen off gaming or you're not haven't
been buying you know up-to-date games so
you see sac phone you like I remember
Frank Zach boy I was a lot of fun and
yet another reason to kind of enjoy it
and you know be a lot of the the
LittleBigPlanet part of it perhaps
doesn't make sense anymore with dreams
existing so it makes perfect sense for
them to take this kind of mascot and
turn him into a just a straight-up like
you know platformer and it worked really
well for you know a showboat so bringing
bringing it back making them a little
PlayStation Mario let's do it is this
what we're going instead of neck-through
you think you know you take take what
you can get yeah all right after that we
had destruction all-stars I don't really
have much to say about that one where
you guys look quirky like rock ruggedly
and like with destructive stuff yeah
yeah yeah it looks like he's got some
food and we'll see and the interesting
thing part of it is like people being
out of the car that's the thing that's
really kind of intrigued me like what
does that mean does that mean that
they're running at the same speed as
cars or they just like wall running at
the same time like what happens to the
call when you get out of it does it just
go into like autopilot what's happening
so I think it's a slight mystery at this
point so hopefully we get more
information about you soon next up is it
Cana bridge of spirits by project ember
so it's Mike and Josh Grier yeah Kenna I
think I think that's how I made a game
yeah it's it's really cute it definitely
has that at least in the character
design it's very much that that Pixar
kind of the big eyes and the round faces
and I think if the main character her
name is Kenneth and
which is a really cute character design
and I think you said this during the
stream Lucy is that it's like horizon
zero dawn made by Pixar and like if
that's also a little bit of a Pikmin
element because of those little things
that it seems like she controls or that
follows her that's yeah yeah and so it
looks like that's gonna be a major
mechanic so you got like a little bit of
a Pikmin vibe to it and so yeah I want
to I want to see more of that looks
really cute I mean like just watching
this trailer again it's it looks like
it's got a lot more depth to it then I
think the I think it's just saying oh
it's got a Pixar aesthetic we should
definitely some more credit right I'm
like that's the three okami
you know anything life back into the
world it's very cute I'm very excited
for that one after Kenna we heard good
bye volcano high from co-op Keo
underscore Opie up in Montreal very big
life is strange meets night in the woods
vibes pure I like I say life is strange
because it's obviously dealing with a
lot of heavy issues it seems but also
like the woods because of the creatures
like these old they're all dinosaurs I
guess I know who all these things are
but the cute it's cute and I wondered
okay I'm like it's difficult to tell
from this like what kind of gameplay
it's gonna be is it gonna be more like a
visual novel or are these just cutscenes
I'm gonna and we're not seeing actual
gameplay yet but it looks like it looks
different and I think that's a really
big cool thing from this reveal like we
were talking at the beginning and we
were expecting things like COD but it's
nice at Sony of putting games like this
front and center in the big psy reveal
yeah there's a lot of variety on show an
impressive amount for you know a
showcase like that we've got we had a
sports game we had adventure games like
indie games action games first-person
shooters like what kind of first this
you know what that counts us but yeah
like a good amount of array and I think
a lot of you
or again really smart from Sony to hit
as many demographics and interest points
as possible and I think that game look
cool and even if even if it's not for
you there's probably a whole bunch of
people out there that are like oh that's
that seems interesting I want to keep an
eye on that
so yeah I'll play it Sony next up odd
world soul storm so we had lawn lining
come and introduce it like looks really
cool I used to play quite love odd
worlds as a kid it's so we carry my the
the the most important thing for me
seeing this is that it sticks to the 2d
odd world the the foundation of the
original odd world games that it is 2d
and I think you know it doesn't it
doesn't mean that the game is going to
necessarily be oversimplified because it
is mostly on a 2d plane like it's
showing off some pretty clever mechanics
and it could still be visually striking
even though it is still adhering to that
that spirit of the original games and
like odd world honestly that is is silly
as it might lean into some of its humor
odd world is pretty heavy and I think
like I don't know the for for a new odd
world game to exist in this day and age
I think they really need to nail that
they really need to go all-in on hitting
those heavy themes with odd world and
you know I I want to see that I I would
hedge my bet on it doing something doing
something good in that regard but
overall like I'm I'm I'm happy to see
odd world in 2020 or well 2020 was
coming out in 2021 I mean let's talk
about so for me the show was completely
stolen by Bethesda they came as soon as
I saw Shinji Mikami I'm kind of glad
that we went live because I made a way a
little squeal but we saw more of ghosts
Wyatt Tokyo
what I think when we yeah I think I
think I've been down that street in
Tokyo like he was talking about how the
ps5 allowed them to recreate Tokyo with
way more authenticity than they thought
and you know actually make you feel like
you're in Tokyo and then all this cool
magic I guess like magic is that the
paranormal stuff happens it's not the
best way to describe it but I love the
fact that it's not it's not fantasy
magic
it looks pixelated it looks like I don't
know like how to describe it like a
retro game or something yeah it's like
like magical futurism something like
that yeah yeah it looks really really
cool so like they they kind of like
detailed a bit more about what is going
on and it's just like you you 99% of the
city's population is gone there's some
weird are caught event and like there's
darkness as like submerged the city and
you have to just go around and kind of
like reclaim it but I think it's just an
excuse for them to do really weird
things around the city and like the
whole thing is like you're seeing
spirits that are kind of inspired by
Japanese like mythology and and kind of
like history so like that the yellow the
kid in the yellow coat is like I think
so I mean I'm a warrior she or something
like that it's like a young kid in a
yellow raincoat and like influenced by
super powerful emotions of sadness and
then there's like Shiro Mookie and
Kusaka other types of demons in there
that are like around the city that you
have to battle and purge from a
first-person perspective which we didn't
expect but I'm super into it after that
we had jet the far shore
so let's holiday 2020 from the super
brothers team who are best known for
sword and sorcery Tom you were super
into this one yes or in sorcery like I'm
my type on this is based entirely of
some sorcery like I love that game I
think is fantastic it's still like super
super good if you download and play
on I think it's on our consoles as well
now or at least a console one of the
Nintendo ones but I originally played it
on iPhone and it's got such a great
soundtrack as well really smart use of
like interactions and gameplay mechanics
so if that studio has been kind of under
the radar for a while now so I'm excited
to see what they've got going and this
looks way more ambitious than anything
they've done before so that team is
incredibly creative and so again like
super super intrigued into what this can
become and and what more there is to it
when they show it we still have like
over 10 games left so let's keep going
god full we did predict that we would
see more of this one I love the look of
the gameplay but I think the music
choice did not do it for me maybe that's
just me nitpicking but like I said was
like a very Borderlands pick and it
didn't seem to fit the tone of the game
based on the gameplay that I was
watching Michael what do you think yeah
I definitely see what you're saying I
think for me it was more of like I no
one knew what the vibe of God fall would
be based on I think what I my
impressions before when it was first
revealed to be like okay this is sort of
like a maybe a God of War warframe style
of game and it's still kind of kind of
like that I just don't know what the
vibe was going to be if it's gonna be
light-hearted if it was going to be
story heavy and I think that eventually
we found out it is supposed to be like a
looter style of melee game and I mean
you know it's it really depends on what
they're what they're going for and it's
hard to tell what they're going for just
based off of visuals and short gameplay
clips so I mean I'll reserve judgment
until we kind of get a better fuller
understanding of the system's mechanics
and kind of the world building around
God fall I'm not surprised that I guess
gearbox would go in this direction with
some sort of more lighthearted less
heavy like you said almost Borderlands
vibes to it so you know there's still
still more to be seen but
yeah I'm definitely getting some
warframe vibes in a more lighthearted
sense just gonna say it'll be
interesting to see whether that's
actually in the game or just like a
marketing thing yeah another game from
Annapurna from the hyper light drifter
hyper light drifter folks so what ash
that's I mean when we were watching the
trailer the color palette actually the
aesthetic of the game reminded me a lot
of Monument Valley but it did look very
pretty I mean I'm excited to see more of
it but at the same time it was followed
up by what we'll talk about a little
because it sunscreen it looks really
pretty yeah
hyper light drifter was one right now
yeah yeah I believe drifter was my one
of my favorite games of 2016 I think it
really it really stuck with me it really
hit me in the way in which it said a lot
by not saying much so I think like Alex
Preston from a hard machine did an
incredible job of communicating that in
such a like a like it's also like pixel
art style so it's very hard to
communicate those things in that art
style so this definitely has that hyper
light drifter vibe but now going in from
like a top-down 2d Zelda type of thing
to a full 3d world and what you said
it's almost like Monument Valley the
sense of scale is so much bigger and I
have a lot of trust in heart-machine to
do to do right by the name of hyper
light drifter obviously because they
made their mark with that game but then
next up a genuine surprise did not see
this one coming
hitman three again like another another
game that if you want to show off like
like how much the technology improves
the game like hitman is a current game
hitman 2 especially people are actively
playing that game is actively being
supported its front of the my on top of
the brain so when hitman three comes out
and you you can almost do a side-by-side
comparison and these are games where
they love a crowd in him
they love putting crowds in hitman they
love some like physics-based kind of
simulations and AI is super important to
hitman and creating these elaborate
elaborate like dioramas for you to walk
through and manipulate and call and see
how the impact like another game that is
going to be very illustrative of the
leap in technology and what it means
even if it's just a starting on that
technology obviously it meant one the
original reboot not the original game
and hitman two the follow-up both
fantastic game some of the best like
action and like strategy and puzzle
solving games in recent memory I'm super
excited to see whether they where they
go with it from here it's the conclusion
of the trilogy they say was which means
the story should be wrapping up for
agent 47 what does that mean how do you
wrap up the story for agent 47 he's the
face of that yeah into four years here
and I hope they they put a shake
Zanzibar in there and he'll meet Kruger
so that's what we need I really just
maintain sense of humor yeah the one
thing the one thing I said when the
reveal trailer went up is that agent 47s
got feelings now because agent 47 is
like the whole history of the franchise
like this very sterile type of clone
person who just knows how to kill
targets and assassinate folks but you
know if we're gonna go deep into some
sort of backstory on agent 47 I want to
see what what they do with that yeah
alright let's let's roll through these
next couples so we've got Astros play
room very cute
I imagine that will be the game that
will really show off the dual sense to
its fullest capabilities little devil
inside so this one looked a little bit
like art style kind of reminded me of
don't starve from team near stream I
think this one was actually a
Kickstarter game from a few years ago um
when I was looking it up but it does
look very cool like it looks know
unique in terms of its like the gameplay
itself like it looks like a big mishmash
of things but I really like that I'm
intrigued the loop will be yeah the
papercraft art style looks really cool
and it's it's a it's a trick to just
make big eyes because everyone loves big
eyes it endears you towards these
characters so look at the size of those
eyes everyone loves it
thank God we're joined by an American on
stream NBA I call o nga to play 21
ballin so we got Zion Williamson front
center I think he's cover a fleet for
every NBA 2k 21 I'm a little surprised
by I guess how little they showed
because all all we saw was you know Zion
Williamson and the he's in the he's just
practicing by himself alone in the
practice court the one thing I'll say is
that he's very sweaty like in a way that
reminds me of the the consistent layer
of shine that the early 360 days had
like so [__] like it's like so shiny
it's at the point where it looks like
fake I'm sure the game was gonna look
great and I know that player likeness is
such an important part of getting
immersed in NBA 2k but I mean I think
they're doing it a little bit much with
the lighting and the reflections but you
know I'm sure they do
I'm sure they did moving on a new game
from the Octodad team I wonder what
they've been working on because often
that came out of like years ago I wasn't
even a GameSpot then I've been here
almost six years so it looks really cute
it's called bug snacks it's a world it
reminded me of like a you know the the
dream that Homer Simpson has where
everything is fun better this is it like
everything let's just taste this food it
looks really cute it looks really weird
and I mean that in the best way like in
terms of a concept everything is food
folks
about the limbs why there's something
skin it's not happening here like it's
there's something really really sinister
happening here cuz this lad is on screen
he's like come to my village come to my
island yeah and he keeps begging and
becoming them like this is some
straight-up cult like yeah come to well
you'll have a great time here and then
when you get there is like my man is
gonna eat you and become you this is all
just like a weird like I love it if it
became like a horror game of slowly and
you're like oh he just wants to eat
everything how do we talk that's a good
transition by the way I know I was gonna
say the transition because I forgot the
dog that's not awkward oh it's the one
that I had a hell of a lot of trouble
with in Dark Souls 3 anyway speaking of
souls Tom are you feeling okay no no I
all I hurt my hand because I slammed my
my desk too hard
and I think I might have fractured one
of my hands something but yeah Demon
Souls like it was one of the things we
said in the pre-show that I would
absolutely love to see and I am so so
happy that people are getting a chance
to play this game and you know I said it
in the pre-show a lot of people their
first experience of this kind of game
might have been Dark Souls and then
they've stuck with it since then and the
unfortunate thing is like there if you
if you came into it post in Dark Souls
and Beyond like it was difficult to
experience Demon Souls and also play it
in the way that it originally came out
it's such a phenomenal game but like now
that it's available like just looking at
these bosses looking at these enemies in
areas it's one of the most I remember
playing Demon Souls for the first time
when it originally came out I I employed
it from Japan and I couldn't really
understand a lot of it but this game
even still even though we've had
multiple souls games we have had souls
clones there's still something in the in
the feeling in the soul
for bone of a bear phrase of this game
that no other game has has has kind of
captured that the feeling of of being
like unsettled and afraid and unsure of
what's behind every other corner that
might sound like every other souls game
and in a lot of ways it kind of is but
there's something the way that this game
does it with ambience and music and
storytelling and general vibe that none
of the other games capture as well like
blood-borne comes close to it
Dark Souls 1 like filing shrines
specifically comes close to it but
boletaria there's something about
volaterrae that it's just quite special
and I'm so so happy that they're
remaking it and I'm so happy that it's
BluePoint they're doing it move point
like out knocking it out of the park of
everything they care if this turns out
to be a bad port it would be a something
for the books because they haven't done
about one of those year they put in so
much time effort and love and you can
watch like our audio logs on Shadow of
the Colossus just to see how much they
thank you yeah like and if they're put
in that is souls wouldn't be why it is
right now if he didn't take a shot on it
and like you can lay the success of that
game from software and everything that
has come in a large part to Shuhei
Yoshida so I imagine he's putting in the
work to make sure that he's bringing it
back as and as it should be in its
entirety so I'm confident they'll have
the network stuff in there as well
it's demon sauce baby let's go
next up oh this one I I'm just like I
love arcane dishonored is one of my
favorite games of all time I always have
dishonored 1 & 2 and death of the
outsider ready to go on my playstation
just to dip in the dishonored to me is
what Mel gear and souls games are to Tam
I I've never been like I've been
fortunate enough to interview the team
at arcane before and I don't think there
is a team that are so artistic ly driven
and have such a focus on the what their
world looks like and how that feeds into
everything
obviously there are huge dishonoured
vibes here that slide the power that
we're gonna see here looks a lot like
blink
it just looks god I'm so excited but the
premise of it it's like a bunch of
assassins caught in a time loop you have
a like a list of people to whack for
lack of a better word and you can rewind
time yeah so many things and like the
more they talk about it the more it's
like god this is just so Kane Sebastian
meat on there who he was the art
director on dishonored and believed he
was actually a fashion designer or he
thinks about that really really
intensely which is why all the
characters have such this gorgeous
unique look to them very stylized and
God this trailer yeah well I'll say
about like death loop is that if you I'm
getting a lot of like if you track where
what are Kane has been doing recently
with like prey moon crash which the
concept of making prey into a rogue
light style of game that's kind of the
message that I'm getting from death loop
and also the the incorporation of
dishonored style abilities with
Wolfenstein style shooting now arcane
did touch Wolfenstein Youngblood which
came out last year so I'm getting a mix
of Dishonored Wolfenstein Youngblood
some of the lessons maybe they learned
from doing prey moon crash all mashed
into one and like the concept is
obviously intriguing the art style is
very intriguing the but the idea of at
least from what I'm getting across is
these two assassins rivals but they're
they're kind of still in like it'd be
antagonist to a privileged society I
want to see where that goes and like
look we got two two black protagonists
front and center here this is this is
arcane can do something very very
powerful something really really cool
with this concept with these two
characters starring in this and
I I shared the same level of excitement
with Lucy in this because this honored
like immersive Sims that is 100% like my
[__] and arcane arcane don't miss they
do not miss when it comes to their games
I love praise so much Dishonored one to
deathly outsider and the whole history
of like Harvey Smith going back to deus
ex I know this is arcane liens but that
that history that that mentality that's
been ingrained in arcane dating back to
like what Harvey Smith is done in the
past way in the past and then now to see
what this is going to be this is
definitely one of the most exciting
games of the next generation for sure
yeah and like the stuff today like as
you mentioned like I love stealth games
like I stealth games are the other thing
that I go crazy about and those two just
wanted one to definitely outsider I've
done like a no spot no kills runs on
them and the thing that I excites me is
like they think about stealth and the
world that they're building in a waiter
so a few others do it's sometimes it
hurts to think I remember having a
conversation with Bing of Aqaba who was
on who introduced the game today and the
way he was talking about how they design
gameplay ideas and bring it all together
and and and kind of like meld it all
into one really immersive experience was
genuinely mind-blowing to me and now
that they're doing it and that was like
within the framework of something that
they were familiar with they have some
experience with with immersive Sims
where you know they had Harvey Smith and
a bunch of them have worked in this that
kind of play field before this is
something completely different it feels
like they're taking that idea and just
like twisting it into something brand
new and fresh and and innovative and I
am so so excited to play this game and
the interesting thing like we didn't
mention it on the on the actual event
for both ghosts while Tokyo and death
loop are it seems like timed exclusive
on PS 5 and so they are launching
they're making console debuts on PS 5 so
I'm surprised they didn't talk about
that but that's something huge
yes a huge feather in Sony's cap for
PlayStation fires if this is the only
place that you're gonna be able to play
them holiday season that's massive but I
mean maybe they didn't do that because
every time a platform holder does one of
those world exclusives permeate like
people at the at the end of it all was
so confused about what exactly that
means and so maybe they just wanted to
have this clear-cut presentation show
off the games like by showing at a Sony
show people are gonna have it ingrained
in their mind that it's a Sony game even
if it is gonna come to another platform
later on just like I assume this next
one will Resident Evil 8 is it is it
Resident Evil like is it in the style
guide now that it can't be called
anything that doesn't fit like the Roman
numerals of yeah so it's close back
village yeah that was that was there I
believe yeah I believe that was like the
working out that the title behind the
scenes like the project title and that's
what leaked earlier it was being called
village so they yeah resident evil man
and really interesting that they it
didn't seem like there was like is there
as an evil wait is this if the vibe is a
bit different from what we'd expect from
Resident Evil
it has like a a voiceover with someone
narrating almost like a fairy tale about
like someone going to get berries and
that kind of stuff but the fact that
they're doing that instead of just being
like very obviously making it clear that
this is a Resident Evil game it makes me
excited that they're they're not just
gonna you know ride the success of the
previous game they're gonna try and do
something stylistically different or
totally different or narrative ly
different obviously the main there is a
connection to Resident Evil 7 in case it
wasn't obvious I really like resin evil
7 and Resident Evil so I'm gonna Yammer
on about it for a bit but like this is
another even story and it's supposed to
end eaten story Chris by referring to
but like the way that Chris came in at
the end and the way that someone was
like like Chris no yeah
so like it's Chris showed up doing
something really interesting with
Christmas with Chris yeah like because
Chris shows up at the end of the last
game he's just in yeah you know he at
the very final sequence I think yeah he
kind of like repels down off a
helicopter he's there so like but this
looks like a very different kind of
Chris and at the time he's working for a
kind of organization that is battling
these kind of traditional zombie style
outbreaks so the fact that he's so to
set up for this game is that Ethan has
moved on from what happened in in the
previous game but then Chris shows up
and instigate something that pulls him
back into another kind of horror and
nightmare he by doing what he does it
sets off this kind of chain of events
that makes Ethan investigate what what
is happening to Chris so this is kind of
like Ethan having to save Chris and it
takes them to this mysterious village
where it all pops off so it could be
really really interesting to have like
Chris in this villain role taking the
most recognizable character from the
franchise's history arguably one of the
most recognizable character the
franchise history costing him as a
villain and then having you've helped
him find redemption that seems like a
really really fascinating way to tackle
the story and obviously being in a
village huge Resident Evil 4 vibes like
the Las Vegas around but now we've got
werewolf's and first-person like yes
present evil let's go all right next up
so this next one we were talking and
when we saw the figure in the spacesuit
we were like Luden's is
jima time throughout the stream you were
saying that your Kojima senses were
tingling and I guess they kind of went
far off this is me but like it's by
Capcom so this game actually looking I
was looking into it the trademark for
this leaked a few weeks ago but like
what is this death drowning is this
kijima yeah it's it's it's it's
something you know it's it's a far way
off oh there's a cat ooh so you know oh
yeah they've got two cat appearances you
know saying but I you know in this
future I want real cats digitize cats
might not do it for me but I'll take
what I can get and in the future when
this game comes out in 2022 we'll find
out what it is because right now we're
just going off based on this trailer so
we don't really know what the gameplay
is like we know a little bit about like
the concept I guess and like tam said
like this is super distracting vibes in
many ways because of how zany it is but
yeah like we're not gonna get many
gameplay details but man is this trailer
like it presents a lot of questions like
what the hell is this I think that's the
strongest thing you can do for a game
that's that far out and yeah I think you
know instilling that mystery in us is is
really important and I just you know
it's one of those things where you just
you just want to know more mmm first of
all where is deep down is is deep down
now secondly I think that I I bet that
character in that space too is not human
I bet that character has some sort of
alien and has come from and the kitty is
kind of like guinea Westra what's yeah
maybe the last human but like that
character in the spacesuit needs to
figure out what happened and why earth
is the way it is now and the kid is the
key to that and you have this kind of
like almost like dipping out of Earth
and then back in to try and fix things
in figure stuff out the fact that it's
coming from Capcom makes me want to try
and pigeonhole it into one of the
traditional genres that they used to
making like you know a character action
game or something like that but I don't
know man there's something about the
filled nature of this that makes me
think of Dragon's Dogma and that was
something that they yet they're like
that was an unexpected game and it came
out of nowhere everyone was like oh this
kind of looks like a Souls game and then
when they started playing it they're
like this is like Loki you won the most
interesting open-world action games in a
really long time
and I feel like we could get blindsided
again in the same way and have this game
pragmas come out be like this has got
intense Dragon's Dogma energy where it's
completely unexpected from Capcom and
it's surprisingly really clever and it's
got some really fascinating things
happening in it and you gotta play it
and we'll see though but just as we
predicted in the pre-show horizon zero
dawn sequel so this is horizon forbidden
West from gorilla looks really beautiful
I mean what can you say about horizon
the great thing about that game that I
really enjoy is the mesh of like nature
but also futuristic machinery but nature
and reclaiming that fact but it looks so
it just looks like it's taken to I don't
want to say another level it does but
like you know what I mean it just yeah I
think I think I like the color palette
is just like intensely angry and red no
please
yeah yeah I think the main thing for me
is the sense of scale like horizon zero
dawn was a huge open world with such
beautiful environments of course and it
pushed the ps4 to its limits even in
2017 because that's what gorilla does
but the sense of scale I think is the
thing that's that's making this feel
like a next generation game and yeah
like when a you see a lie looking over
these cliffs I mean we've seen it in
games like Red Dead Redemption - but to
this to this extent is something else
because remember it in if we take their
word on it this is all in game footage
so this isn't like pre-rendered stuff
for
well they're using the end game engine
so if this is the experience that we're
gonna get I think this this horizon for
Midwest trailer or reveal is
communicating a lot of the types of
experiences that we can expect from the
PS 5 and just how much bigger worlds can
feel I mean we have games with huge open
worlds all the time but it's it's
different when it's visually
communicated just how big these
environments are but also yeah I think
you mentioned Lucy that like the color
palette there's the sense of dread that
is kind of that that's the first
impression that you get when you're
looking at this new horizon game and of
course like horizons you're done being
the first game in the series it has to
do a lot of world building has to ease
you into those sorts of things but here
it seems like you know a LOI because it
also leads in with a monologue of a
alloys saying like I will do anything to
save this world and I'm ready to go and
it shows they're going to all these
different biomes so the sense of dread
the sense of intensity is just like
right off the bat that is what the
players are that's what they're
communicating to the players and I'm all
for that
I like to rise a zero Don very much I'm
curious to see how they depict like
Native parallel lifestyles and tribes
because that's one thing I think they
can't improve on is the depiction of
that but yeah horizons forbidden West
this is you know in a way it's kind of
what we expected but we're still
impressed by seeing it I think is one
thing that I picked up on there is that
I remember playing horizon at the same
time as playing breath of the wild and
breath of the wild is the game that I
kept defaulting back to because of the
freedom it offered you to climb
literally anything and I know it was
some climbing in horizon but it felt
restrictive like you could see a place
and you could eventually get that you
couldn't just scale a wall but I mean he
was climbing something there and I
really hope that they have taken board
and increased her movement and just like
putting you in this beautiful world
giving you all the tools to go around it
and cool it's like it's some kind of
plague or disease
she says like I must find a way to stop
it or it'll get worse and destroy us all
like the the conceit has been set up you
know this is what you're this is what
you're doing so you're placed into this
world to do and I just can't wait to
just clamber all around it and just
explore it mmm tell me you think and and
the kind of thing that excites me is
like how much of the like like Michael
said they're like the the variety in
like the cultures and worlds that they
show him if like we had like the Asian
looking kind of like dragon like
futuristic holographic dragon thing and
that's one of the one of the things that
you know is what I think was the
strongest part of the first horizon game
zero dawn is like the the amount of a
care and attention that they put into
crafting this kind of culture and a
world for that culture to exist into and
like Michael said again like that the
scale of it seems way bigger like we're
seeing the underground underwater stuff
here now like there's an L o is kind of
hanging around underwater she's got like
breathing apparatus and this makes me
think of like an entire underwater
civilization where she needs to you know
kind of saw some stuff out and explore
and basically Gungan City let's let's go
but then like asian asian like areas and
like different biomes and cultures to
figure out and understand and piece
together that's one of the most exciting
things about for me i think you're right
in that the they will have no doubt paid
attention to the various changes and
design innovations and steps forward in
in games like breath the world and other
games assassins that kind of stuff to
see how it all how they can improve and
i would be very surprised if that wasn't
in there so horizon zero dawn already
one of the coolest games of this
generation one of the most like
satisfying games to play i'm interested
in seeing what happens to a lawyer as a
character now she's moved beyond this
kind of she had a you know kind of
awakening in the in the last game and
then a character arc that was very much
focused on figuring out her place within
the world and now it's shifting to now
she has that confidence and knows who
she is
I'm interested
seeing how she's characterized and she's
becoming more of a hero for the world
instead of someone lost and adrift
trying to find some steady ground to
Purvi on so it gives a gorilla a lot of
new material or like tone and themes to
work with narrative Li so I'm excited
see that definitely well what a
fantastic showcase from Sony and the
PlayStation 5 final thoughts Michael Oh
impressive showcase you know I think one
thing in comparison to what Xbox and
Playstation has done is that Xbox likes
to like drip-feed their little by little
they show more and more and more but I
think PS Bauer PlayStation and Sony they
hold their cards close for the big
reveal
and that's kind of what we got here and
it's it's very satisfying man like of
course this week was supposed to be e3
but this definitely felt like that scale
of event with all these different games
I mean a lot of them are gonna be
multi-platform games but some of the
PlayStation exclusives Demon Souls
remastered bro that's wild Resident Evil
8 would first reveal horizon for bid and
West like heavy hitters up front and
like we got to see the PS 5 which is I
mean like for me it's an incredible
looking console like I wanna I want to
have that I want to show that off in my
spaces whatever so I really think Sony
and PlayStation knocked out of the park
with this one there's a lot to be
excited about still a lot of questions
about some of the games that they did
show off but I mean like that's that
comes with the territory and yeah of
course even more excited about PS 5 than
it was before the reveal event of course
yeah I still like everything that I saw
there and I think we saw there was
impressive and exciting I think as a
first real look at the PlayStation 5 and
and a first real showcase of what people
can get excited and should get excited
about
I think Sony pulled it off pretty
fantastically it was a excellent event
Microsoft have been doing an amazing
work already and I'm excited and kind of
energized for it now this feels like
next gen
is really happening now and I'm so
excited to see what they have Microsoft
and Sony I still have some questions
like across various things like the
spider-man thing it ended with you know
them saying you know be yourself play
yourself or something like that what
does that mean for the game is it like
customization I have other questions
about like price then release day
specifically Sony just for our statement
or an on statement where they said we're
gonna talk about that later and so
hopefully that doesn't take too long I
think the big question is where those
people rendered or not there was a big
theory going around yeah we're like
everyone who was every human
representative of a video game look
weirdly uncanny valley ish to the point
where there was a theory that maybe
they're all rendered in playstation 5
some sort of engine and there wasn't a
bezel that would be cool like I still
watched it I think it might have been
the lighting and they're like depth of
field or something like that but there
was a bit uncanny valley happening there
we've kind of reshot sony to be like
yeah well those people real so we'll see
if they're like what the hell are you
talking about yeah Jim Ryan's a real
human yeah talking about pride of the
Northeast Jim Ryan by the way Oh very
own Jim Ryan bring up Jim right but yeah
I think that was a huge huge success and
I think everyone's excited about it and
a good solve for Sony yeah just one more
things oh oh one more thing like said
questions about what how the consoles
gonna function we saw a little bit of
the home screen but we didn't get a much
else other than that in terms of how the
console functions so a lot of questions
backwards-compatibility
our ps3 EPS two game's gonna be
integrated if that I know there's been
some rumblings about that how are some
other features that Xbox have shown off
such as like swapping between games
smart delivery how across house cross
generation gonna work well like are we
gonna be able to house ghosts of
Tsushima house last was part 2 going to
work on PS 5 are there gonna be
improvements is it just gonna play it
straight up so still a lot of more
questions so it's easy to get caught up
in the hype and I love getting caught up
in the hype but still
keep in mind that there are still things
to be answered which will of course be
answered closer we get to console launch
holiday 2020 definitely all right thank
you everyone for joining us
keep it game spot for all the rest of
the huge reveals that are coming you
know we have that Ubisoft event we have
EA we have that there's gonna be more
from Microsoft as cyberpunk
there were so many digital events will
be doing a pre and post-show for all of
them thank you so much for joining us
and if you are so inclined if you want
to donate to black lives matter as well
as Direct Relief we're running daily
charity streams with some of your
favorite gaming personalities so make
sure to check back and join us there
Michael Tom thank you so much we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]